[Music]
how do you maintain a normal life at all
traveling so much cuz you're you're
never home for thirty years of my life I
was a chef and a cook which meant I woke
up early in the morning I work in
kitchens with a bunch of other
dysfunctional sort of marginal
characters for twelve or fourteen hours
a day then went out and hung out with I
didn't know any normal people I work
holidays I I worked the weekends like
most working cooks and chess Duke so
even though I'm traveling over 200 days
a year I'm probably leading a more
normal stable life than I did as a cook
and as a chef I tried my own way to
create some kind of stability in normals
and a normal seat in my life and and on
balance I think I have certainly
compared to the way I lived the first
80% of my life but what's a regular day
like at home when you're not on the road
if at all possible favorite thing to do
sit around on my pajamas with my
seven-year-old daughter watching
cartoons cooker cooker lunch cooker
dinner do nothing that would be that
would be a best-case scenario if there
are three piece of advice that you had
to give to people
you must go here you must eat here right
what were those three places be I'll
give people the advice to eat street
food you know when you're if you're if
you're in India it may not seem like a
good idea to eat street food people ask
me all the time but don't you get sick
you are much more likely in my
experience and the experience of my crew
into doing this for 14 years now you're
much more likely to get sick eating at
the hotel buffet
what's eat what's good and what's
beloved locally if people are proud of
their food and they're selling it in the
street that food is for their neighbors
theirs they're not still in business by
poisoning their neighbors so you know
street tacos in in Mexico
street food in in Asia these are these
are great and joyous things that enable
you to actually you know experience a
culture where it counts how have you
managed now I'm becoming the brand of
hoard a you are a chef but now people
look at you as like this is the guy who
travels the world he's a taste maker
he's tasted every food this is who we
turned look I'm not a brand I'm a guy
who's having a lot of fun and I'm a
guy's having a lot of fun in his life
and trying and try not to screw up how
much longer do you think he can do it
I'm gonna keep doing this as long as I
could get away with it who wouldn't
[Music]
you